with the january 6 hearings happening
throughout june one person who is
actively trying to avoid their questions
is peter navarro he was charged by the
doj for ignoring two subpoenas from the
january 6 committee then he filed a suit
against the committee and the doj and
now in a true trump-like drifting
fashion he's on tv begging for money for
his legal fund
[Music]
former trump advisor and infomercial
salesman trying to sell you money-making
secrets peter navarro just to catch
everyone up to speed peter navarro was
one of the key authors of the plan to
overturn the result of the 2020 election
one of the others was steve bannon you
know the guy who looks like he's a mix
between dandruff and a rotten tomato
navarro was charged by the doj with two
counts for contempt of congress for his
refusal to comply with the january 6
committee the first charge was for
refusing to appear for a deposition and
the second charge was for failing to
provide information on the green bay
sweep navarro outlines the green bay
sweep in his book taking back trump's
america why we lost the white house and
how we'll win it back jesus christ
that has got to be the world record for
longest book title he stated that the
sweep was designed as the last best
chance to snatch a stolen election from
the democrats jaws of deceit navarro
said the plan was to have lawmakers on
capitol hill debate the electoral
results from six swing states in the
hope of having congress declare the
results to be in dispute navarro claimed
that president trump was on board with
the strategy and then up to a hundred
congressmen were committed to executing
the plan however the plan was dependent
on vice president mike pence who opted
not to participate you know the same
mike pence that all of trump's followers
wanted to hang on january 6 during the
insurrection
oh and by the way trump was totally okay
with that happening anyway navarro has
been claiming that the january 6
committee is a sham and that he is
completely innocent despite the fact
that he goes on tv and openly admits his
involvement in trying to overturn the
election most recently he was on ari
melber show risking going potentially to
jail
not to talk to them
but you're out here
talking in public
you do realize these investigators
can hear you when you talk on tv in the
very next day navarro was arrested by
the fbi
wow i guess karma is a real thing all
right is it just me or has anyone else
noticed a theme with navarro's outfit
because every time i see him on newsmax
or fox news or remelber show he's always
wearing the same outfit white shirt
rolled up sleeves and a tie navarro
reminds me of a high school basketball
coach whose team is down by 20 in the
fourth quarter with three seconds to go
and in a moment of desperation he pulls
out a whiteboard and tells us that we
need to drive up the middle and give
trump the ball to win the game this guy
is an absolute joke but actually now
that i think about it i've seen this
look before he reminds me of jim cramer
you know one's a traitor and the other
is a traitor so in the spirit of this
segment let's make a quick adjustment
much better from day one navarro has
claimed he was protected by executive
privilege well guess what he doesn't
have it so navarro then appears to fall
back on the vague assertion that the
executive privilege here belongs to
former president trump which is not only
dubious but entirely irrelevant because
our committee has not been given any
attempted invocation of executive
privilege by donald trump navarro
reminds me of george costanza's dad just
throwing up his arms and exclaiming
executive privilege now
so when navarro addressed reporters
after being indicted by a grand jury for
contempt of congress charges he
complained about how he was treated
unfairly and had to stay in john
hinckley jr cell
which is a weird thing to brag about
instead of calling me and say hey we
need you down at court
we've got a warrant for you i would have
gladly come what did they do
they intercepted me getting on the plane
and then they put me in handcuffs they
bring me here they put me in leg irons
wait what was that they intercepted me
getting on the plane and then they put
me in handcuffs they bring me here they
put me in leg irons leg irons navarro
was notorious for lying again the guy
tried to overturn the 2020 election so
while lake irons on navarro would be a
great thing to see i highly doubt they
put more than handcuffs on the guy and
to anyone out there who doubts me get me
photos of navarro and leg irons navarro
says he would have gladly shown up if
they had asked and to that i say
[ __ ] navarro was arrested at a dc
area airport while attempting to fly to
nashville to meet with former arkansas
governor mike huckabee aka thewish.com
version of ernest hemingway navarro uses
more green screen backgrounds than
hollywood blockbuster films so excuse me
if i don't believe navarro or huckabee
about flying to do an interview when he
does all of them from his basement
navarro is 100 of flight risk and then
in true navarro fashion he went on to
tucker carlson's entertainment show to
cry some more instead they went with
this shock and awe terrorist strategy
yeah let me go to the airport and then
take me with five agents like i'm a
al-qaeda terrorist maybe this is navarro
projecting and he thinks he actually is
a terrorist i i don't know i mean he did
try to overturn a fair and safe election
and now navarro is begging for money by
asking people to buy his book it's the
same one that i mentioned earlier with
the really long title my book taking
back trump's america i need everybody in
america to buy that book on amazon
taking back trump's america jesse
because that book is going to be my
legal defense it's on amazon this book
taking back trump's america help me
please i do not want to spend several
hundred thousand dollars on lawyers well
this is going to cost a half a million
dollars i'm looking at a half a million
dollars in legal expenses according to
some legal experts or more this could go
to a million that's going to basically
wipe out my retirement savings and i'll
be eating dog food navarro's next court
appearance is set for june 17th so who
knows maybe we'll find out more details
about who or what navarro is covering
for and hopefully the january 6
committee will have those details to
share with us or navarro just admits to
his crimes during an upcoming tv
interview because if there was anyone
who could talk themselves into a jail
sentence it's peter navarro well i'm
gabe sanchez and this has been what was
that
[Music]
you